[Music]
in joke gone wrong news oh I feel like
we'd get that off yeah
submitted by happy tiny no yeah JK
you're the dog I think Canada's Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau regrets the
people kind joke he made after receiving
backlash I saw this kind I don't know a
Trudeau that really handsome man so
little backstory they're very liberal
over there and I wanted to confirm
because I heard that you got I wanted to
let you continue but I my tightness so
hard on my foot started to hurt so this
is kicking pad for muy Thai roundhouse
kick while it's on your foot because
because it reminded me of sandals so my
toe started going down so I knew it's
okay that's super liberal and I had to
confirm cuz I was I heard that out there
you could get in trouble for not calling
people by their own oh yeah and I was
like what is that that's all I was like
it's again twitter twitter followers
canadians tell me the truth
can you get in trouble for calling
people you know not by the pronoun that
they want to be called yes you can get
fined or jailed yeah you could get
arrested because it's it's it by it it's
considered hate speech and I thought it
was [ __ ] up because if you
accidentally call someone he yeah when
they want to be called she that means
you who get in trouble for hate speech
without knowing make no sense man yeah I
think that's a little too far huh I feel
like
intent would play a role in that but
we're also you viewing it as people from
the US that are like sooo happy maybe in
Canada that are like oh my god I'm so
sorry I didn't underline don't live in a
world like that do it I can't do that
I can't do that I like because like hey
I'm actually a she I'm like my bad man
this is cool and then we leave it at
that
well the response was not like average
citizens and everyone was like not
doesn't even affect us there's just it's
it's into law but whatever no one's
really enforcing it yeah I don't know
yeah so so Trudeau was he attended a
town hall-style meeting in Alberta when
a woman called vimentin him for
recognizing the ability and power that
women actually possess and then she went
on to say that maternal love is a love
that's going to change the future of
mankind and then that's what he
interrupts her and says we like to save
people kind I'm necessarily mankind it's
more inclusive and then everyone just
starts laughing just trying to get more
[ __ ] she's making a joke that's
hilarious yo I get it cuz we're taking
the man out again a few minutes people I
get it
yeah and so that just went by wrong no
I'll show you guys that I agree show you
guys the extinction we shouldn't use
manicure we should use woman cure cuz
it's for women's hands and feet yeah
here we go
you can also be changed because maternal
love is the love that's going to change
the future of mankind so we'd like you
to look what we like to say people kind
not necessarily mankind more inclusive
yes thank you we can all learn from each
other so he's saying that that was a
dumb joke because he was saying like it
played well in the room yeah needs
contact she's getting flam but I don't
get it why well cuz if you look at the
video alone it sounds like and if you
don't know the backstory anything it
looks serious
mm-hm it's like he's taking it serious
oh look at the video that I saw there
was no cheering after that it was just
him telling her we like to say people
kind cut so this is how the news or the
bias I see if I don't know anything
about the President or the Prime
Minister if I don't know anything about
what's going on in Canada right now all
I see is someone correcting someone and
it's kind of sjw and overtly PC way too
politically correct yeah but if it's a
joke and they're making fun of the whole
political correctness and it's like Oh
funny funny times it's being smooth and
like yeah he's messing around charming
there's one tweet saying that face when
a man tells you you're the wrong type of
feminist and then like another one says
on behalf of Parliament to the woman he
interrupted I apologize for his behavior
PS I'd love for him to interrupt me like
that so I just saying like the fact that
he interrupted her is like so rude and a
mansplain - yeah immense blaming is what
they're saying - you know what though it
is kind of fear it is kind of serious
and like what is weird it is kind of
weird because they change their national
anthem from man mankind or for the sons
or something like all of our sons to all
of our people that's pretty cool that's
cool but I think with all those changes
are crying though probably didn't [ __ ]
up and right I don't know I don't even
know my own at national anthem so you
know our national anthem do you know it
it's a
stand or not stand I don't know what
we're you know which one I thought it
was I'm a Yankee Doodle thing if that
was our national anthem I kind of want
it I don't know yeah I've got reminded
thanks to you guys star-spangled banner'
yeah I know the title
did you just whip because you got the
answer right and then you hid the letter
so the word comes up spark star-spangled
banner' and you go just explode is
[ __ ] amazing you know it exploded
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like a Vanna White of the MMA
yeah so those people kind of common
thing that sucks
I feel bad for dude you just caught up
on words so sometimes that happens when
you police words so much now you're
getting policed by your words yeah
they're like it's not people kind it's
human kind
it's not human time it's human you will
in fact how about I don't give a [ __ ] go
to your job and work there and get a
[ __ ] paycheck you've done [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't mean women I mean everybody
which kind I'm sorry what's the man's
blaming it's when a man interrupts you
to explain I do that a lot
well they're trying to explain from what
I understand is it like you're trying to
explain a woman something that a woman
experiences or like what she has
experienced but the guy doesn't know but
he's trying to explain it to her when I
tell you about Larry it's like let me
tell you how it's really sick yes yeah
like I saw some example of like some
scientist woman she was making a comment
in her field and then this dude was like
well no do you know like and he ended up
using her as a reference without knowing
that it was her
I took my cues mansplaining to her
quoting her own material dude what how
gratifying is that that's so funny
oh I would [ __ ] calm cuz I'd be like
yeah well then you can't defend yourself
you'll be too tired that doesn't happen
for women bro that's just guys I'm sorry
I'm sorry sorry man splitting my coming
yeah so what happens for men is oh yeah
we know what happens for men we've been
there we get energy
come on Google what it is please man and
flame I am I am so curious what is a
mansplain he wants to try to get his way
out of North I just don't want to be
guilty of man's plane so it's as
mansplaining of a man explains something
to someone
typically a woman in a matter in a
manner regarded as condescending or
patronizing
woman manner warm manner so
condescending speaking condescending
speaking yeah to a woman woman topics
specifically women totally interrupting
a woman to explain it that's just a cost
and they're nice men yeah we do that to
each other all the time you could say
that to your dad then don't man's blame
to me I'm not sensitive so I I am I'm
gonna start using it
David don't you [ __ ] mansplaining
sack of [ __ ]
what's woman splaining that woman's play
me when you don't make sense nurturing
[ __ ] what are you talking circles what
okay woman is playing in us when you're
offended about everything no woman's
planning is when they recall an event
that doesn't happen the actual way that
it does because it happened in a brain
if she imagined exactly it was the
correct way that it happens yeah oh that
I've woman explained plenty of times
made up my own history and got mad at
Jess I did it before Molly you're saying
your memory is not flawed no because
that's why they don't believe in I
witness testimonies by the way my point
so men do it too I never said that it
was gender you did specific said women
you did it no he's saying that he will
miss planes all the time now you're now
you're backing him up no he's a woman's
place all the tell everyone to everyone
with a dick in this room is wrong I'm
gonna cut it off that you prefer to be
called today
- eh now we're just two [ __ ] time to
fight this stuff is like so divisive it
is horrible within the household it's
[ __ ] breaking up people
I'm saying are they doing this on
purpose so they make us [ __ ] finally
divide and conquer you're just giving us
more ammo to use on each other you want
us to be weak divided before they want
to destroy our lab they want to destroy
our friendships they want to destroy the
community you know what it is it's so a
politician can come in and be like they
are trying to hurt you and they and I
will save you and that's how they keep
their jobs that you know six-figure
incomes that's us their cushy ass jobs
and then they go to balls together with
people that they're like that's the
enemy and then they go to like balls
together and they dance and and then
they take each other's balls
yeah and they single Joe's balls right
now cuz I thought these were their
testicles rubbing against each other
what they're making the world do right
now is act like a junior high school
first day of dance girls on this side
guys on this side and nobody want to
make the first move
[Music]
[Music]
you